>> Dana: REPUBLICANS VOWING TO
MAKE DR. FAUCI'S LIFE VERY
DIFFICULT AS THE EXPERT HANGS UP
HIS LAB COAT.
HE WILL BE STEPPING DOWN AS
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CHIEF MEDICAL
ADVISER IN DECEMBER ENDING
NEARLY A HALF-CENTURY IN
GOVERNMENT.
DR. FAUCI HAS BEEN A LIGHTNING
ROD OF CRIBBAGE CRITICISM OVER
HIS HANDLING OF THE PANDEMIC AND
PUSH TO LOCK DOWN THE COUNTRY.
WHEN OP-ED SAYS HE SHOULD SIMPLY
FADE AWAY.
"NEW YORK POST" EDITORIAL BOARD
SAYING GOOD RIDDANCE TO
DR. FAUCI, COVID GUIDANCE
DISASTROUS.
MAKING THE MEDIA ROUNDS TO
DEFEND HIMSELF FROM THE
ONSLAUGHT.
WATCH HERE.
>> WITH COVID, I MEAN, THE
THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT WE KNEW
IN THE BEGINNING TURNED OUT AS
THE MONTHS WENT BY TO NOT TO BE
THE CASE.
THAT WAS INTERPRETED BY MANY AS
FLIP-FLOPPING OR NOT REALLY
KNOWING WHAT IS GOING ON, WHEN
IT REALLY WAS THE EVOLUTION OF
THE SCIENCE.
>> THERE IS A WEIRD OBSESSIVE
VIOLENCE ONGOING DEMONIZATION OF
YOU BY THE RIGHT TO THAT IS
HINGED ON COVID.
>> WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH NOW
IT'S JUST A DISTORTION OF
REALITY.
MAKING IT LOOK LIKE TRYING TO
SAVE LIVES IS ENCROACHING ON
PEOPLE'S FREEDOM.
>> Dana: WHILE HE MIGHT BE
DONE WITH HIS JOB AND CONGRESS
IS NOT DONE WITH HIM,
REPUBLICANS VOWING THEY WILL
HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE IF THEY WIN
BACK CONTROL IN NOVEMBER.
>> DR. FAUCI, RETIREMENT OR NOT
IS GOING TO BE SPENDING A LOT OF
TIME IN FRONT OF A CONGRESSIONAL
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEES IF
REPUBLICANS TAKE BACK CONTROL.
>> HE HAS NOT EVER TESTIFIED IN
FRONT OF THE HOUSE SINCE COVID
STARTED.
SO THERE ARE SO MANY QUESTIONS
THAT MEMBERS HAVE.
WE HAVE ARTIE TOLD DR. FAUCI TO
PRESERVE ALL OF HIS DOCUMENTS.
>> I HOPE THAT REPUBLICANS TAKE
CONTROL THAT THEY WILL GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF EVERYTHING FROM
THE ORIGINS OF COVID TO ALL OF
THE MANIFEST FOR ELDERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTABLISHMENT
PARTICULARLY DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
>> Dana: SO GOING TO SAY
GOODBYE IN DECEMBER, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> Tyrus: HE AIN'T GOING
NOWHERE, HE WON'T WEAR A MASK ON
"THE MASKED DANCER."
HE WILL BE EVERYWHERE AND WORK
ON THROWING PITCHES AND DOING
EVERY POSSIBLE TV SHOW AND WILL
GIVE DR. DREW PINKY A RUN FOR
HIS MONEY INTO HIS TOURS AND
STUFF.
THE ONLY THING AT THIS POINT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON IS GETTING THIS
COUNTRY BACK ON TRACK.
THE REPUBLICANS GET THE HOUSE,
START FIXING THINGS THAT MATTER,
CHASING DR. FAUCI, BECAUSE HE
CAN ARGUE WITH SCIENCE IT'S LIKE
ARGUING WITH SOMEONE'S RELIGION,
APPARENTLY HAD CHANGES ALL THE
TIME.
SO THAT'S GOING TO BE HIS
DEFENSE.
WE DID NOT KNOW THIS, BUT NOW WE
KNOW THAT.
IF I KNEW NOW WHAT I DID NOT
KNOW THEN, BUT IT'S GOING TO BE
A LOT OF STUFF AND IT'S GOING TO
GET AWAY FROM THESE HUGE
DISTRACTIONS.
HE IS GONE, HE WAS SMART, HE
LEFT BECAUSE HE KNEW THE FIRING
WAS COMING.
SO HE KEEPS HIS PENSION AND WE
WILL DEAL WITH HIM ON TV SHOWS,
BUT WE NEED TO GET BACK TO
BUSINESS INSURING UP WHERE THE
NEXT TIME SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS WE HAVE PEOPLE IN PLACE
THAT DON'T MAKE THOSE KIND OF
MISTAKES.
>> Dana: HE DID A LOT OF MEDIA
AND ACCEPTED ALMOST EVERY
INVITATION.
HERE IS A MONTAGE OF SOME OF THE
MEDIA REACTING TO DR. FAUCI'S
DECISION.
>> ALWAYS PUSHING FOR SCIENCE
FIRST AND PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
WHITE HOUSE FROM AT TIMES
EXASPERATED HIS FACE AND HAND.
>> THE DOCTOR WHO GUIDED THE
U.S. THROUGH THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC AND SAVED COUNTLESS
LIVES.
IT'S BECAUSE THERE IS NEVER BEEN
ANYONE ELSE LIKE HIM AND NEVER
WILL BE AGAIN.
>> HE WAS THE FACE OF THE
MESSAGING AS HE WAS PUSHING
STRATEGICALLY AND DIPLOMATICALLY
AGAINST A PRESIDENT WHO OFTEN
WAS PUSHING THE WRONG DIRECTION.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S AN
EXAGGERATION TO SAY THAT THERE
ARE MILLIONS OF HUMAN BEINGS
ALIVE TODAY WHO WOULD NOT BE
ALIVE IF NOT FOR THE WORK THAT
DR. FAUCI DR. FAUCI DID
COORDINATED AND LED.
>> Dana: I WONDER IF THEY
WOULD SAY THE SAME ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OPERATION
WARP SPEED, BUT MAYBE NOT?
>> Jesse: WHY ARE THEY
TREATING HIM LIKE A DANGEROUS
CLACK?
WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE THAT THE
LOCKDOWNS DESTROYED SMALL
BUSINESSES AND GENERATIONS OF
CHILDREN, DID NOT SAVE LIVES,
LETTING PEOPLE CROSS THE BORDER
IN DROVES UNVAXXED, BUT DON'T
FLY IN FROM CANADA?
WHAT IS HE DOING?
HE HAS DESTROYED THE COUNTRY,
YOU DON'T DO THAT AND THEN GET
TO RIDE OFF INTO THE SUNSET.
ONLY DEFENSE SECRETARIES CAN DO
THAT.
RIGHT NOW HE HAS COME OUT THE
DAY HE ANNOUNCED HE WAS RETIRING
AND WENT ON THE MOST LIBERAL
NETWORK IN THE COUNTRY AND DID
AN INTERVIEW WITH THE MOST
LIBERAL HOST IN THE COUNTRY AND
PRAISE THE PRESIDENT WHO WAS
ELECTED AND SAID I'M NOT SURE
WHY PEOPLE THINK I AM POLITICAL.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT PEOPLE
THINK YOU ARE POLITICAL.
HE NEEDS TO COMPLY WITH EVERY
SUBPOENA THEY SLAP HIM WITH AND
IF HE DOESN'T, WE SHOULD SHACKLE
HIM AND MAYBE WE SHOULD WRITE
HIS HOUSE AND LOOK FOR COLLUSION
WITH CHINA, BECAUSE THOSE ARE IN
THE NEW RULES APPARENTLY WE ARE
JUST PLAYING BY THEM.
HE SAYS THAT HE WAS JUST TRYING
TO SAVE LIVES.
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN WORLD HISTORY
I JUST TRIED TO SAVE LIVES?
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE A
DANGEROUS ANALOGY, BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO GET CAUGHT DOING
IT.
BUT I HAVE A FRIEND WHO HAD A
HURT LEG WHO GO SO THE DOCTOR
AND SAYS DOCTOR, MY LEG REALLY
HURTS.
OKAY, WE WILL DO SOME SURGERY,
PUTS THEM UNDER, AMPUTATE HIS
LEG.
HE SAYS I CAN'T WALK ANYWHERE,
HE TOOK MY LEG OFF.
AND THE DOCTOR SAYS I WAS JUST
TRYING TO SAVE LIVES.
THAT'S DR. FAUCI, THEY ARE
REALLY DUMB DOCTORS THAT DO DUMB
THINGS THAT ARE BETTER THAN A
JOB, DOES NOT MEAN THAT YOU HAVE
TO KISS THERE BUTT ON THEIR
FAREWELL TOUR.
>> Dana: ALSO DID NEIL CAVUTO
EARLIER TODAY, LET'S PLAY THAT.
>> I DID NOT SHUTDOWN ANYTHING.
THERE WAS A LOT OF CONSIDERATION
AMONG THE WHITE HOUSE TASK FORCE
AND THE RECORD WILL SHOW, NEIL,
THAT WE DID NOT RECOMMEND
SHUTTING EVERYTHING DOWN.
WE WANTED TO CAUSE A PAUSE.
>> IT'S EASY TO BE EMANATED
QUARTERBACK HERE THAT IT WENT
TOO FAR, PARTICULARLY FOR KIDS
WHO COULD NOT GO TO SCHOOL
EXCEPT REMOTELY THAT IT FOREVER
DAMAGE THEM.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT IT FOREVER
IRREPARABLY DAMAGED ANYONE, BUT
OBVIOUSLY AND IF YOU GO BACK AND
PEOPLE SELECTIVELY, NEIL, PULL
THINGS OUT ABOUT ME, I WAS ALSO
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT SAID WE
HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
GET THE CHILDREN BACK IN SCHOOL.
>> Dana: JESSICA, DO YOU THINK
LOOKING AT THE LONG ARC OF
HISTORY TO GET HIS LEGACY
CORRECT?
>> Jessica: I HOPE SO, THIS IS
A MAN WHO HAS WORKED FOR SIX
PRESIDENTS AND SOMEONE WHO UNTIL
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHEN I
THINK THE DEMONIZATION OF THIS
HEALTH BUREAUCRATS WENT
COMPLETELY HAYWIRE CIRCULATED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA WITH HIM IN THE
IDEA THAT REPUBLICANS THINK IT
WILL BE A GOOD MIDTERM STRATEGY
TO RUN ON ALL OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS THAT THEY
WILL HAVE ON HUNTER BIDEN AND
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI WHEN PEOPLE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT KITCHEN
TABLE ISSUES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, I WELCOME IT.
BUT WHEN I THINK ABOUT DR. FAUCI
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT THINGS
WERE NOT MISHANDLED AND RACHEL
HAS BEEN DOING WITH WHAT THE CDC
GOT WRONG, I WILL BE THINKING
ABOUT 2014 WHEN HE HUGGED THE
NURSE THAT CONTRACTED EBOLA, HE
PERSONALLY TREATED HER.
THAT IS SOMETHING HE IS FAMOUS
FOR THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER.
AND WHAT HE DID IN THE 1980s
DURING THE EPIDEMIC.
HE LOBBIED THE GOVERNMENT TO
MAKE SURE MORE PEOPLE COULD GET
INTO THE CLINICAL TRIALS.
AND HE SAVED COUNTLESS LIVES.
SO THIS MOVE TO ALWAYS REDO
SOMETHING TO THE LAST MINUTE IN
TIME AND TO FORGET DECADES OF
SERVICE, I THINK IT'S A HUGE
INJUSTICE.
AND AGAIN, IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT
I THINK THAT THINGS WERE
PERFECT, BUT IT IS A WILDLY
UNFAIR READ OF THIS MAN'S
CAREER.
AND I THINK THAT IT IS AN AWFUL
AND PAINFUL END TO SOMEONE WHO
HAS GIVEN THIS COUNTRY THAT MANY
DECADES OF SERVICE.
>> Jesse: HE BLEW IT BIG TIME.
>> Tyrus: HE WAS A GREAT
PRESIDENT UNTIL THAT WATERGATE
THING.
>> Jesse: HE BLEW IT.
>> Rachel: IT WAS THE BIGGEST
TEST AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT
COVID IS A KITCHEN TABLE ISSUE
STILL FEELING THE EFFECTS OF IT,
AND IT WAS NOT JUST A DOCTOR IN
AMERICA COMING AT
INTERNATIONAL --
FOR ALL OF THE REASONS YOU SAID
INTERNATIONAL POWER AND FAME
100 MILLION PEOPLE ARE NOW IN
POVERTY BECAUSE OF THE LOCKDOWNS
THAT HE WAS BEHIND.
AND AGAIN, LOOK AT HOW THE
PEOPLE THAT HE HURT.
IT'S NOT JUST CHILDREN.
HOW MANY OLD PEOPLE DIED OF
LONELINESS?
HOW MANY PEOPLE DID NOT GET TO
GO TO THEIR FUNERALS OR HOLD
THEIR HAND, THEIR MOTHER AND
FATHER.
HIS BIG MISTAKE WAS HE DIDN'T
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
THE SCIENCE OF NATURAL IMMUNITY,
AND IF HE HAD RECOGNIZED WHICH
WAS SCIENTIFIC AND ESTABLISHED
AT THE VERY BEGINNING, WE WOULD
BE IN A DIFFERENT PLACE TODAY.
BUT BEING ANTHONY FAUCI MEANS
NEVER HAVING TO SAY THAT YOU ARE
SORRY, BECAUSE THE MEDIA IS
FUMING THIS GODLIKE COMPLEX THAT
HE HAD.
THE LACK OF HUMILITY YOU JUST
SAW.
THE GUY THINKS HE IS GOD.
HE IS LIKE AN AUTHORITARIAN
MONSTER AND LET OUR COUNTRY ON A
CHINESE STYLE APPROACH INSTEAD
OF AN AMERICAN STYLE WHERE WE
LOOK AT SCIENCE AND CONSIDER ALL
OF THESE GREAT SCIENTISTS WE
HAVE IN THE COUNTRY INCLUDING
THE ONES WHO SIGNED THE
PARROTING DECLARATION AND TRY TO
SHUT THEM DOWN, SHAME THEM,
CENSOR THEM, THAT'S NOT --
AND HE HAS TO BE --
>> Jessica: AT THE COMPARISON
TO CHINA IS LUDICROUS WHEN THEY
LEAVE FISH OUTSIDE YOUR DOOR
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT THAT YOU
OUT, COME ON, THE KEY PEOPLE
PEOPLE INTO CONCENTRATION CAMPS,
RACHEL.
>> Rachel: HE WAS AN APOLOGIST
FOR THE CHINESE AND WAS
NONTRANSPARENT WITH THE LEFT AND
THE ORIGINS AND WE ALL NEED
TO --
AND BY THE WAY AT THE LAST THING
I WANT TO SAY IS THE REASON WE
NEED THESE HEARINGS IS BECAUSE
IT IS SMART FOR REPUBLICANS
POLITICALLY BUT IMPORTANT FOR
THE COUNTRY.
WE DON'T WANT TO REPEAT THIS AND
WE NEED TO PUT HIM IN THESE
HEARINGS TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT.
>> Dana: THE CDC COMING OUT
WITH THE FINAL REPORT SOON, AS
YOU MENTIONED, COMING UP,
GAVIN NEWSOM CRACKING DOWN